[Music]
in the midst of the George Floyd tragedy
hundreds of surfers in New York's
Rockaway came together in their own way
to honor his life and to protest against
racial injustice 'as when things
happened in the community you got to
speak up on it
and you're silent good violence why
speak my mind so you don't listen you
ought to listen but 300 people listened
and they came and it was beautiful
[Music]
I'm Lou Harris on the East Coast found
out the black self association and we
provide free surf lessons free
skateboard lessons for the kids of
Rockaway a lot of kids don't have money
to stay for board that's why I'm glad I
get donations and I get to give them
away for free
will do surfing on Saturdays from 8 to
10 and then we'll do skateboarding from
11 to 1 Saturdays and same thing on
Sundays and during the summer it's every
day I got into surfing as I moved here
15 years ago and I needed an outlet I
needed something to do I've walked up to
the boardwalk on beach 90th Street and I
saw people surfing I'll sit this surf
here
I taught my son how to surf and I've
been surfing ever since you know I start
big way small ways hurricane wait I
remember there wasn't too many black
surface this is me maybe a couple other
kids he's young you know
african-americans they live here and
they should know what goes on in their
own backyard you should know the sandbar
you should know the drop-offs you should
know all that it's good for young kids
to get exposed we can I want kids to see
that the lamp doesn't have to be
particularly white off and that's what
it usually is it's great to see a black
face here in their Spanish space here
Asian face here
Lu's mission uses surfing not only to
empower kids in his community but also
as a tool to bring people together and
recently he did exactly that Liu
organized a paddle out to raise
awareness for black lives matter a
paddle out is most the time when a
surfer dies you paddle out into a circle
and you throw flowers into water and you
splash the water today was a great
paddle out because we got to say all the
black lives matters I thought it was
gonna be a hundred people this was over
three hundred and I'm still in shock
I'm just happy who came and look again
I'm blown away but you know white people
they'd was starting to chance they don't
want hey no justice no peace
it's black people getting killed but
this was predominantly white people and
they beautiful people and they getting
sick of it too
when people see me out you know they
don't see a surfer they see a black eye
but this is my backyard and I love it
today was probably the most successful
day of my life being african-american
man I mean my little voice started a 300
person movement today
[Music]
you
[Music]